[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos un
vídeo sobre las elecciones mexicanas
hablamos de las elecciones más
importantes de la historia de mexico que
a su vez es el país más grande del mundo
hispanoparlante y por qué son tan
importantes pues porque son las primeras
donde méxico podría estar diciéndole
adiós al bipartidismo
andrés manuel lópez obrador 10 9 puntos
arriba de su competidor más cercano pero
esperad un momento porque hablar de
bipartidismo en mexico es mucho decir
para que os hagáis una idea este país ha
tenido al mismo partido en el gobierno
durante 70 años tal cual como lo oís
desde el año 1930 hasta el año 2000
todos los inquilinos del palacio
presidencial también conocido como la
residencia de los pinos venían del
partido revolucionario institucional
como se puede ser revolucionario
institucional al mismo tiempo no lo sé
pero ese es el nombre que le dieron a
este partido aunque se le conoce mejor
por sus siglas el pri
el pri es algo así como el gran partido
del centroizquierda mexicano y sí ya sé
que muchos mexicanos no estaréis de
acuerdo si digo que el pri es de
centroizquierda pero pensad que tengo
que hacer un resumen para que lo
entiendan todos los que vean este vídeo
incluyendo los que lo ven desde otros
países lo cierto es que el pri estuvo
gobernando méxico por 70 años después
del año 2000 tuvimos 12 años de
gobiernos del partido acción nacional
también conocido como el pan que es el
gran partido del centroderecha mexicano
ya en el año 2012 es cuando el pri
volvió al poder esta vez de la mano de
enrique peña nieto- también conocido
como el presidente peor valorado de la
historia de mexico pues bien es ahora en
el año 2018 cuando los estados unidos
mexicanos afrontarán el 1 de julio unas
elecciones decisivas y quien es el
candidato con más posibilidades pues ni
el del pri ni el del pan el posible
nuevo presidente es este señor que veis
aquí que se llama andrés manuel lópez
obrador
y empresarios preocupados por las
propuestas de andrés manuel lópez
obrador en materia económica esta sería
la tercera vez que se presenta a las
elecciones y parece que va a ser la
definitiva
lópez obrador o como se le conoce en
méxico amlo se presenta con propuestas
que están generando como decirlo pánico
pánico entre los inversores
internacionales y el empresariado local
algunos incluso dicen que méxico podría
convertirse en la nueva venezuela sin
embargo el mayor enemigo de hablo en
estos momentos no es otro que el mismo
sus declaraciones generan miedo entre
los votantes más moderados que podrían
lanzarse en masa a votar alguno de los
otros candidatos
[Música]
así que llegados a este punto la
pregunta es por qué hablo puede ganar
las elecciones cuáles son sus propuestas
y lo que es más importante hay razones
para tenerle miedo puede hacerle sombra
a alguno de los otros candidatos hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la gran decepción mexicana a comienzos
del siglo 21 parecía que méxico se iba a
comer el mundo
[Música]
con multitud de recursos naturales
incluyendo el zumo de dinosaurio o la
plata por citar algunos y siendo una de
las economías emergentes mejor valoradas
por los inversores en 2010 el país llegó
a crecer en un 55 por ciento sin embargo
al igual que ha ocurrido con otras
grandes promesas como brasil o sudáfrica
esas grandes esperanzas mexicanas se
terminaron de desinflar en el año 2016
vive en dólares de mexico en su nivel
más bajo desde 2010 todo esto es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que
méxico tiene todas las posibilidades
para triunfar pensando bien tienen
petróleo un buen clima para la
agricultura y toda clase de recursos
naturales además hacen frontera con el
mayor mercado del mundo eeuu de hecho si
lleváis tiempo suscritos a visual
político ya sabéis que méxico tiene un
tratado de libre comercio con eeuu el
llamado nafta tlcan
[Música]
de hecho el 80% de las exportaciones
mexicanas se dirigen a su vecino del
norte pese a todo esto méxico sigue
siendo un país de renta media con
sueldos bajos y un nivel de vida muy por
debajo del de eeuu o canadá y os
preguntaréis por qué pues veréis después
de 70 años de endogamia del pri de
corrupción y de narcotráfico méxico
vivía con unas instituciones
prácticamente medievales y ya sé lo que
me diréis por seca creo que estás
exagerando un poco verdad puedes juzgar
por vosotros mismos
hasta el año 2016 en su sistema judicial
no existía la presunción de inocencia y
ni siquiera había que reunir pruebas
para decretar una culpabilidad en muchos
casos bastaba con una confesión obtenida
con tortura policial para meter a
alguien en la cárcel para que os hagáis
una idea
los expertos llamaban a este sistema el
modelo inquisitorial tal cual como lo
oís a esto hay que sumarle el
narcotráfico que ya se ha llevado por
delante a más de 200.000 personas en
sólo 11 años
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en algunas
zonas de mexico los narcos tienen más
poder que el propio estado a esto en
ciencia política lo llamamos una
situación de estado fallido y es lo que
tienen en muchas zonas de áfrica y
también en muchas zonas de mexico en
otras palabras que méxico necesitaba y
necesita algo más que reformas necesita
dar un giro de 180 grados a sus
instituciones y quien era la persona
indicada para hacer este trabajo pues
nada más y nada menos que enrique peña
nieto- que llegó al gobierno en el año
2012 el problema que todavía es muy
pronto para que los mexicanos noten
mejoras sustanciales en su nivel de vida
es más las desigualdades sociales no
hacen más que crecer y por supuesto no
podemos olvidarnos de otras cosas como
por ejemplo el gasolinazo del que os
hablábamos en este otro vídeo
a eso hay que sumarle que el mayor
problema de peña nieto es el mismo peña
nieto- pocas personas han trabajado más
duramente por hundir su propia
credibilidad
básicamente peñanieto lo tiene todo
casos de corrupción que afectan a su
propia persona una supuesta tesis
doctoral falsa y tráfico de influencias
de todo tipo por si esto fuera poco
cuando donald trump estaba en campaña
electoral insultando los mexicanos todos
los días al presidente de mexico no se
le ocurrió nada mejor que invitarle para
un debate como si ya hubiera ganado las
elecciones pero sin haberlas ganado
y qué me decís de la lucha contra el
narcotráfico después de haber encerrado
a el chapo guzmán que sería algo así
como el pablo escobar mexicano va y se
le escapa de la cárcel y además escapa
de la cárcel a través de un túnel al que
sólo le faltaba aire acondicionado vamos
que a nadie debería sorprenderle
noticias como esta
[Música]
mi encuesta en mexico peña ni tos el
presidente peor evaluado en definitiva
aquí el gobierno de peña nieto ha
representado para los mexicanos la
decepción definitiva con los políticos
ante este panorama con el pri lejos de
ser un partido en el que confiar y el
pan ofreciendo una alternativa muy poco
atractiva los mexicanos han perdido sus
esperanzas en los partidos tradicionales
es el momento de hablo
pero quién es andrés manuel lópez
obrador un tiempo en el que andrés
manuel lópez obrador militó en el pri
fue en los años 70 cuando se afilió al
partido dominante de mexico pero por
aquel entonces ya era más institucional
que es revolucionario y por eso ambos se
marchó y fundó el partido de la
revolución democrática el auténtico faro
de la izquierda mexicana
sin embargo derrotar al pri parecía una
misión imposible hasta el año 2000 el
año de la gran debacle del pri
[Música]
en ese momento los conservadores del pan
llegaron al gobierno y amlo llegó a ser
alcalde de la ciudad de mexico ser el
alcalde de la ciudad más grande de toda
latinoamérica es el mejor escaparate
mediático que puede tener un político
candidato a las presidenciales de 2006
lópez obrador apenas se quedó a 250 mil
votos de los pinos y qué haces cuando
casi ganas unas elecciones y eres algo
así como la rockstar de la izquierda
mexicana pues básicamente realizas
acusaciones de fraude electoral
organizadas por de estas callejeras y
dejas que los tuyos de nombre en el
presidente legítimo todo esto puede ser
un anticipo de lo que podría pasar si
las urnas vuelven a alejarle de los
pinos dije en la democracia se gana o se
pierde en la democracia entonces no hubo
democracia
a todas luces bueno
y equitativa
y
la garra y os preguntaréis pero cuáles
son sus propuestas básicamente habló
propone dar marcha atrás en
prácticamente todas las reformas que
aprobó enrique peña nieto en otras
palabras una vuelta al pasado
queréis ejemplos pues hasta la reforma
energética todo el petróleo mexicano
dependía de la empresa estatal pemex que
tenía unas pérdidas enormes y toda clase
de corruptelas peñanieto y todo el
monopolio de pemex y permitió que
pudieran invertir en el país las
empresas extranjeras por supuesto en el
corto plazo esto tuvo sus consecuencias
y ya lo vimos todos y el precio de la
gasolina en méxico subió dramáticamente
en muy poquitos días como recordaréis
esto tuvo sus consecuencias en el corto
plazo y en muy poquitos días el precio
de la gasolina subió dramáticamente pues
bien habló quiere solucionar este
problema volviendo a la situación
anterior y lo mismo pasa con la reforma
educativa como veíamos en este otro
vídeo peñanieto quitó el poder a los
sindicatos de profesores y nuevamente
lo propone devolvérselo y os
preguntaréis qué propone para acabar con
el narcotráfico pues atentos porque esta
es buena
anb lo no sólo quiere acabar con la
guerra contra el narco que podría ser
razonable sino que además no descarta
una amnistía de hecho ha llegado a
pronunciar frases como esta estos que
presentan como los grandes delincuentes
son niños de pecho en comparación con
los políticos corruptos del país pero
sin duda lo más sorprendente de amlo son
sus recetas mágicas por ejemplo cómo
podemos acabar con la corrupción pues
muy sencillo para hablo es tan fácil
como redactar lo que llama una
constitución moral eso y quitarles la
inmunidad a los diputados del parlamento
que por cierto esto es algo que siempre
me ha hecho mucha gracia a esa supuesta
relación que hay entre la inmunidad
parlamentaria y la corrupción lo hemos
visto en varios programas electorales de
otros países y os voy a contar un
secreto en los países menos corruptos
del mundo como
a zelanda o dinamarca también tienen
inmunidad parlamentaria como os quedáis
pero de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo lo
cierto es que amlo tiene soluciones
rápidas y sencillas para todos que hay
paro juvenil pues muy fácil
el gobierno dará trabajos para los
jóvenes que la gasolina es cara no hay
problema el gobierno construirá nuevas
plantas de refinado y así con todo en
otras palabras que hablo y su movimiento
político que se llama el morena genera
tanta simpatía en una mitad de mexico
como pesadillas en la otra pero hasta
qué punto está dispuesto a llevar estas
propuestas a cabo ahora mismo lo vamos a
hacer
popular o populista quedaos con este
nombre alfonso romo se trata de un
empresario de monterrey al que ha
contratado amlo para ser el portavoz de
la campaña y cuál es su misión no os
preguntaréis pues simple y llanamente
moderar el discurso de amlo
con todos los sondeos y encuestas de
intención de voto a su favor
amlo necesita acercarse al centro
político y para eso alfonso romo es la
persona ideal no solo viene del mundo de
la empresa lo que contrasta con ese
perfil tan de izquierdas de amlo es que
además romo ha apoyado siempre a los
candidatos conservadores del pan y no es
el único en realidad dentro del equipo
de campaña de morena podemos encontrar
toda clase de perfiles bastante más
moderados que su líder y su presencia ya
se está notando recordáis que os decía
que amlo proponía acabar con la reforma
energética pues ahora alfonso romo
asegura que lo que se hará es algo así
como una revisión de los contratos
otorgados a las compañías extranjeras
pero matizando que bueno a ver en
general las cosas se han hecho bastante
bien
o algo así andrés manuel lópez obrador
ya cambió de opinión y dice sí a la
apertura energética según alfonso romo
pero no sólo eso cuál creéis que ha sido
la última medida de amlo para
tranquilizar a los empresarios pues
veréis resulta que amlo es de un estado
que se llama el estado de tabasco y por
esa zona hay un pez que se llama el peje
desde entonces habló muchas veces
también se le conoce como el peje pues
bien para reiterar que no va a ver
nacionalizaciones ni expropiaciones ni
impuestos altos ni ninguna de esas cosas
que asustan a los empresarios ha lanzado
su plan económico y lo ha llamado el
peje no mix
[Música]
lo cierto es que por muchos nombres
llamativos que quieras utilizar si hay
algo en este mundo que busca seguridad y
que no le gustan los experimentos es el
dinero así que mientras se acercan las
elecciones los empresarios parece que ya
han elegido cuál es su opción la opción
que eligen entre el pri o el pan porque
hay una cosa que es muy importante en
méxico no hay segunda vuelta así que el
que tenga más votos el 1 de julio será
presidente por tanto la alternativa a
amlo empieza a fuerza y el
preferido para hacerle frente es ricardo
anaya el candidato del pan
[Música]
a élite empresarial mexicana cierra
filas con anaya para frenar a lópez
obrador con 39 años
anaya es el más joven de los candidatos
y ha sido acusado de blanqueo de
capitales pero lejos de ir en su contra
está acusación le ha servido para
presentarse como víctima del juego sucio
del pri que quería debilitar le desde
entonces es un valor al alza pero aún
tiene mucho que remontar en las
encuestas para poder superar a amlo
[Música]
así que ahora la gran pregunta es creéis
que amlo conseguirá llegar por fin a la
presidencia o en el último momento
veremos algo así como el efecto anaya es
amlo un riesgo para méxico o es difícil
hacerlo peor que sus predecesores
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a este canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like compartirlo con
vuestros amigos y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]